do you know how much how much Adidas
lost yesterday for dropping them does
anybody know how much 200 million five
percent of uh five percent was a drop
off so zoom in a little bit let's read
some of this data that we have here
Adidas terminates partnership with Yi
Kanye following rappers anti-semitic
remarks the German sportswear giant had
faced pressure from public and its own
employees to cut ties Adidas said that
they would have a short-term negative
impact of 250 million euros on net
income in 2022 due to highly
seasonability in the fourth quarters
talent agency CAA confirmed it has
dropped Kanye as a client Monday and he
was let go by uh uh uh what's that one I
can't see it can you zoom in CAA CIA
CAA last week okay so stock that's right
creative artists agencies one of the
biggest ones damn WMA I think it's like
a couple those guys up there yeah all
right so guess what Adidas supported
Colin Kaepernick stock went up I'm sorry
nice supported Colin Kaepernick stock
went up the next day Adidas drops
Kanye's stock goes down uh we can still
see Adidas being right for the decision
they made for dropping Kanye and his
positions the part with Kanye that he
kept doing
uh you know there's a phrase uh I use
when I say you know Saint status Saint
status is like when he was talking and
saying certain things and he was taught
my politics in California all I thought
about is does this affect his dad's
career and I said not really because
these are insane status it's Tom Hanks
like Hey listen man Tom Hanks is in a
movie guess what you and I are doing on
Friday night we're watching Tom Hanks
period you gotta line up with what we
got uh Saving Private Ryan one of the
most emotional movies of my life because
I joined the army Hunter and friends and
they said there's a movie coming out
you're going to be the first to see it
before the World season we sat there we
cried like a little freaking baby at the
end saying did I make my life count and
his wife's looking at him saying it's
okay babe you were in tears these guys
are going to save this guy's life price
Saving Private Ryan because what because
he's the only one that's left to
continue you got uh all these other
movies
Toy Story Catch Me If You Can saving
privacy legal their own he's
uncancelable he is he's not freaking Tom
Hanks this guy but but no but he is in
that status of goat status this is I
watched blackout for music for music he
is I watch Black Adam this weekend what
song is in Black Adam what's up Kanye's
song I Think It's called Power Power
yeah the Facebook song or The Social
Network the movie talk about timing you
come out with that movie in a way you're
kind of supporting his song at a time
like this Black Adam just came out this
weekend and the main song one of the
main songs in the movie is his this
guy's one of the greatest artists we
ever had but he thinks they can't touch
him he's Untouchable well uh
unfortunately gonna keep doing this to
him a conversation that we continually
have here is how do you remove the art
from the artist right whether that's R
Kelly whether it's Michael Jackson
whether it's freaking Kanye now you you
you can't compare those three put them
in the same category this guy didn't a
lot of people would put him in that
hip-hop category in of talent or or in
hip-hop Kanye is on go oh not not with
what they did with their personal lives
I'm just saying art and Artistry I'm
just saying separating the two whether
it's whatever the issue is no no whether
it's Picasso whether it's Michael
Jackson whatever the Jackson Kelly's
issues are different than Kanye's issues
bro you can't put those he would be
offended if you compared those three
together the point is like I'm
separating the musical Talent right from
the personal life of the person which
seems to be in a downward spiral not
Michael Jackson R Kelly status buddy you
know it's like it's like you trying to
compare some father uh uh TV dads with
Bill Cosby no
Bill Cosby was a mess so the the
personal what Bill Cosby did
is a different story of what he was
being accused for this guy's just being
accused for saying words that are
offensive
not what R Kelly did
not what Michael Jackson's being accused
of he parents would come over and the
kids would go upstairs saying he's going
to play with them and the parents are
downstairs eating food and hanging out
that's kind of weird fair point I'm just
I'm just saying musically gifted
as a person it seems like he is in a
goddamn Free Fall well this is like what
I was kind of trying to touch on earlier
right like I I really don't know what
Kanye said or didn't say so I I can't
really speak on it obviously
anti-Semitism semitism is terrible
obviously everybody should love
everybody obviously like gross General
generalizations on any group of people
is it is the epitome of ignorance but I
don't know what Kanye said I also know
that the media you could you could say
you know it's a nice breeze today and
the media will somehow skew it as saying
you're in the middle of a [ __ ]
hurricane you know what I'm saying it's
like this is what you're saying because
I've experienced that myself right like
when I did the Jamaican accent right you
yeah okay nobody like I was the one on
my phone like reading the comments okay
what I noticed when that happened is
that it was an outpouring of of love
like pure love from Jamaicans okay I
like it was incredible like Jamaicans
people were commenting messaging me
in Patois you know giving me so much
love and respect because they knew that
I was showing love to their culture
right it was an outpouring of love and
support from actual Jamaicans
meanwhile that it was on CNN it was on
CNN that I did the Jamaican accent and
they labeled me as as mocking Jamaican
culture and being a cultural
appropriator right so it's completely
I've I've noticed personally and I've
been personally offended by the way the
media
can can attack people and and make a
[ __ ] you know a mockery of the truth
right so I I've I've seen that firsthand
right and I I I I and I take it and I
took it personally I took it personally
because I said that's not [ __ ] true
Jamaicans people from Jamaica are giving
me the most love and you're and you're
talking about all these social justice
Warriors that are labeling me a villain
for doing the accent so like
what's the [ __ ] there's a huge Bridge
here between the truth and what the
media is portraying that's a fact all
right so I think that's what you were
what you were what you were speaking on
Patrick right yeah I'm just I'm just
going to a point where so first of all
um
the comment he made is the following
comment okay Kanye West says he'll go
death Con 3 on Jews
and now remove tweet zoom in I'm a bit
sleepy tonight but when I wake up I'm
going Defcon 3 on Jewish people the
funny thing is I actually can't be
anti-semitic because black people are
actually Jews also uh you guys have
toyed with me and tried to blackball
anyone who ever opposes your agenda
okay first of all when you're saying I'm
a bit sleepy tonight you should have
just slept instead of just tweeting that
comment out having said that uh you know
you know Elon Musk called him and they
had a conversation ticket I don't know
if you guys know this or not type in
elamas called Kanye West and he told
them hey you may want to kind of you
know in other words just chill on what
you're saying here here we go zoom in so
we can read this one here Elon Musk says
he spoke to Kanye West about
anti-semitic tweet called a little lower
so Elon Musk revealed on Twitter Monday
night okay actually let's read his tweet
okay uh uh welcome back to Twitter my
friend talk to you today and express my
concern about his recent tweet which I
think he took to heart okay cool there
you have it hey you said something bad
let's talk to you don't say that again
man you're offending people what is that
all about what were you thinking when
you tweeted that out
and then you move on this will not be
the last time a human being said
something dumb
and we will also say things dumb and
when you say something dumb you're going
to want to Hope people remember how
forget how uh forgiving you were to not
put the standards of walking on water
because then you're going to want some
people to say hey like you remember when
Cuomo was getting canceled
and Andrew Cuomo was getting canceled
and everybody was coming after him and
he was bashing Trump for what he did and
then stories came about Andrew Cuomo
you're like oh man you acted like a
saint until now the stories are being
talked about you and now you made Trump
look like the idiot and now you're the
one that's actually being canceled and
fired as a governor where you have to
resign because of what you did dude you
may want to judge a little bit less
we're in a society where we jump to
conclusion we want to judge everybody we
hate I'm sorry I'm not a LeBron James
fan I'm not a LeBron James fan period I
don't like his policies but I have to
tell you
I have to understand that this guy was
raised without a father to make it where
he's at today where his kids love him
his sons admire him and they want to be
like him when they grow up and he named
this kid LeBron and his son decided to
change his name to brani and he was okay
with that and they're still best friends
I don't like this guy's politics but man
you gotta respect this guy as a father
so we have to sit there and say dude I
don't agree with you but I don't want to
judge you I don't want to because if I'm
judging you I'm expecting myself to be
perfect and I'm God and you're not in
there so that that was my point is that
what's so hard about
about refraining from judging a person
just because of an opinion that they
share it's like taking every single
opinion that someone says as like a
personal attack this is like the normal
now every single person is walking
around on any public figure that they
don't even [ __ ] know on anything that
comes out of their mouth they take it
personally this is a personal attack on
me and I have a right to be offended and
I have a right to join the Crusade to
[ __ ] cancel you right whereas you
could just not give a [ __ ]
what's so hard about not giving a [ __ ]
what's so hard about saying I don't
[ __ ] know that person so I can't
judge them I haven't met them I haven't
[ __ ] shook their hand I haven't
looked them in the eye before I don't
know who they are all I know is about a
[ __ ] a word that came some words that
came out of their mouth that's not
enough criteria for me to make a
judgment on this person as a as a
[ __ ] person so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]